faut changer nos évaluations les
évaluations de type traditionnel
dissertation travail à la maison doivent
être beaucoup plus encadrés ça veut pas
dire qu'on les enlève ça veut dire qu'il
faut modifier notre façon d'enseigner
c'est aussi une occasion qu'on a de
repenser notre enseignement donc c'est
pas forcément
je pense qu'on peut céder à la panique
mais comme tous les outils
technologiques ça demande un peu
d'attendre à tadaptation
les professeurs au cégep il y a
l'université doivent composer avec une
tricherie nouveau genre réalisé à l'aide
d'outils comme tchat jpti alors le
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle va tellement vite que la
Fédération nationale des enseignantes et
enseignement du Québec demandent un
moratoire c'est vraiment un cri d'alarme
qu'on lance et aujourd'hui il y avait
une table de concertation il y avait
1000 personnes réunies à discuter de ces
questions dans matière d'éducation
focaliser là-dessus l'impact de
l'intelligence artificielle sur
l'enseignement au niveau supérieur on
pense au cégep à l'université déjà ça
bouleverse beaucoup d'habitudes et ça
soulève beaucoup d'inquiétudes mes
invités Normands bonsoir normand comme
philosophe essayiste qu'on peut lire
régulièrement dans Le Devoir bonsoir
Monsieur notre invitation et Madame
quenelle la présidente de la Fédération
alors écoutez ça écrit de l'arme que
vous lancez puis vous avez entendu par
j'imagine ces mille personnes là qui
étaient là aujourd'hui
je peux saluer le geste de la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur d'avoir
réuni le tout le monde autour de cet
enjeu là qui est un enjeu vraiment
important c'est un cri d'alarme
effectivement d'aller vers un maratoire
ce moratoire là et tu sais la prendre un
pas de recul il est très important de
faire en sorte que il y a une réflexion
qui soit approfondie une réflexion nous
on réclame une réflexion indépendante
une réflexion à laquelle le milieu sera
invité à participer dans ce moment c'est
la pagaille dans la classe c'est la
pagaille il y a pas de directive il y a
pas de fil conducteur qui dit qui qui
accompagne les enseignants et même les
étudiants j'imagine normand berger vous
avec le poids de recul vous avez écrit
des textes cet hiver là-dessus dans Le
Devoir un moratoire même si les
technologies sont déjà là et qui sont
peut-être incontournables j'applaudis à
cette décision là je pense que c'est une
bonne chose de prendre un moment de
recul de réfléchir d'autant vous savez
que c'est phénomènes-là se déploignent à
grande vitesse et on voit pas très bien
où ça sent bon difficilement prédire ce
qui va arriver je fais le pari que c'est
dans cinq ans j'envoie cette entrevue là
je vais être un peu gêné des choses que
j'ai dit aujourd'hui parce que ça va
probable sur l'arrivée de l'Internet
vous avez dit j'étais pas gêné de relire
le test que j'avais écrit
mais je recommandais la prudence et de
prendre du recul ça va être le cas
encore mais là c'est encore plus
spectaculaire encore plus étonnant et ce
que je pense sincèrement aussi c'est que
ça va nous forcer à revoir des
catégories que comme philosophe je
trouve central en éducation repenser ce
que veut dire enseigner à partir du
moment où il y a ça repenser ce que veut
dire évaluer à partir lorsque ceci
apparaît lorsque repenser à ce que ça
veut dire savoir comprendre voilà des
choses qui vont être remodelées par cet
outil là prendre le temps de réfléchir
avant de l'implanter surtout ne nous le
cachons pas qu'il y a des intérêts
économiques majeurs derrière mais ça
menace le savoir ça menace
l'enseignement c'est très possible que
ça menace de savoir et je voudrais
apporter une nuance à ce que je viens de
dire probablement des avantages aussi
aujourd'hui je me posais des questions
je demandais en question ça peut être
avantageux imaginez un étudiant ou un
élève qui travaillent en équipe et qui
demande qu'on lui lance des idées sur un
sujet il peut rapidement obtenir
imaginez quelqu'un qui demande une
explication faite en des termes simples
permettez-moi une anecdote quand
j'enseignais la philosophie moi une des
choses les plus compliquées que j'ai eu
à expliquer c'est qu'est-ce que quand tu
entends par des jugements synthétiques a
priori donc je veux des manières
d'expliquer ça mais imaginez un étudiant
dans ma classe que pas bien compris ça
va avoir du pété puis disait
explique-moi ça avec le vocabulaire
d'Homer Simpson je dis n'importe quoi
mais ça pourrait
passer
en réalité la menace elle est là c'est
le danger du plagiat l'impossible de
détection la facilité la superficialité
c'est tout ça la question du plagiat
elle prend une nouvelle dimension
puisque si on pose une question à chaque
GPT une fois et que un étudiant produit
un texte avec cette question là
l'enseignant va reposer la même question
mais la réponse ne sera pas la même et
donc la détection même du plagiat va
devenir devient bien plus compliqué et
on peut masquer le très certainement ces
éléments là mais je dirais que la
question de l'authenticité c'est un des
éléments un des risques qu'on peut
détecter mais il y en a d'autres la
question je voudrais de la propriété
intellectuelle de la véracité de la
recherche de la manipulation des
informations parce que c'est grand on
parle d'intérêt commerciaux qui est
intéressé par l'intelligence
artificielle ce sont de grosses
compagnies qui vont de l'intelligence
artificielle pour faire de l'argent mais
aussi pour avoir nos données et en
échange ces données là nourrice ce grand
magma duquel surgissent d'autres
questions il y a vraiment lieu de se
poser des questions et de réfléchir
sérieusement à l'impact plus large mais
aussi sur les étudiants sur la valeur de
leur diplôme pas seulement en classe
mais aussi sur la production même du
savoir depuis quelques années on voit
apparaître un phénomène des paper mills
des machines des individus qui font des
articles qui sont publiés des articles
académiques dans des revues
scientifiques on imagine ce que j'ai
pété peut donner comme paperville si
vous me pardonnez une expression comme
usine à produire des articles ça peut
être quelque chose de profondément
dramatique pour la nature du savoir pour
la l'authenticité du savoir qui est
produit mais j'ai dans une classe tout
le monde recours à chaque député pour la
même question ou le sujet de travail
tout le monde arrive avec la même
réponse ou avec des informations avec
des réponses différentes chaque répéter
va donner des réponses différentes pour
ces questions là c'est là que c'est
difficile et là on peut utiliser enfin
un nouveau logiciel qui va essayer de
détecter l'authenticité si ça a été créé
par un ordinateur si on arrive à un
résultat autour de 75% d'authenticité
puis 25% probablement fait par
l'ordinateur qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
ça ce que c'est un flagès est-ce que
c'est avéré
il faut repenser toute cette question là
de de
production intellectuelle c'est
important je pense la solution elle est
pas seulement dire on va être en classe
puis on va on va prendre un dictionnaire
papier puis on va s'asseoir avec un
crayon en classe par exemple à court
terme c'est une solution mais je pense
que à plus long terme il faut repenser
la façon de d'évaluer la façon
d'enseigner parce que on a des étudiants
là le savoir la question de savoir c'est
pas c'est pas de reproduire simplement
je vais attendre je vais voir mais
est-ce que ce dont je suis persuadé
comme philosophe excusez moi de revenir
là-dessus mais c'est qui c'est des
catégories centrales dans le monde de
l'éducation vont être profondément
bousculés par exemple on est obligé de
se demander qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand
on évalue qu'est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
veut simplement quelqu'un rendre un
texte puis qu'il soit conforme à ce
qu'on voulait et ce qui demande des
compétences ou des habilités non vu
qu'ils sachent alors qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire savoir comment on le sait on
pouvait tricher auparavant maintenant on
peut tricher d'une manière augmentée par
je sais plus combien de pour cent mais
on veut toujours que l'évaluation
témoigne que l'étudiant sache des choses
et pour ça ben ça faisait par exemple on
va peut-être recommencer à questionner
les étudiants sur leurs travaux te
explique te dit ceci tu as écrit ceci
c'est censé toi qui l'écris reformule le
moi dans tes mots redis-le moi explique
le moi avant ou pour les choses et ce
sont et c'est ça que l'évaluation doit
nous donner c'est sûr qu'on veut parler
évaluation on est obligé d'y repasser
même chose avec des catégories comme
enseigner et d'autres comprendre vous
savez déjà que il y a eu on a des
étudiants où recours à chat du piti
depuis novembre dernier vous allez c'est
la première session complète ou les
étudiants au collégial puis à
l'université ils ont eu recours et je
vais peut-être reprendre
ce changement là se fait sentir mais ce
que ce qu'on peut déplorer c'est le fait
que le poids le poids de de la quête et
sur les épaules les enseignants des
enseignants qui en fait session ont
corrigé beaucoup de travaux faut penser
à cette perspective là c'est pas une
c'est pas une responsabilité
individuelle c'est une responsabilité
collective et c'est pour ça qu'on
appelle un moratoire forum indépendant
pour trouver des balises établir des
chars et ça il faut impliquer là
jusqu'au au plus haut niveau le
ministère le gouvernement
de réunir le meilleur savoir dont on
dispose sur ces questions là pas
nécessaire au hasard des idéologies pas
laisser ça au hasard des
expérimentations plus ou moins bâclées
au hasard des grandes entreprises qui
sont derrière tout ça il faut absolument
faire des recherches sérieuses les
synthétiser un institut national
d'excellence en éducation serait utile
en ce moment
alerté l'opinion publique cet hiver avec
d'autres scientifiques sur les
dimensions éthiques de l'utilisation du
recours
c'est difficile de prédire j'ai noté le
nom Harry vous souvenez le monsieur qui
a écrit sapiens
si on vous disait que la moitié des
ingénieurs qui ont participé à la
création de l'avion sur lequel vous
allez monter était à 10 % que certains
que tout le monde mourait dans un
accident qui se produirait et ben il lui
dit que c'est ce qui s'est produit avec
l'intelligence artificielle les sciences
les 700 scientifiques formaient
là-dedans je pense que ça c'est à 10%
dangereux pour la survie même de
l'humanité à côté de ça il y a des Benji
est un homme inquiet aussi puis il y a
d'autres gens que je respecte très fort
qui dit on s'inquiète pour rien alors
qu'est-ce qui arrive qu'est-ce qui en
est je ne le sais pas mais donnons-nous
la chance d'y penser et de nous
renseigner le plus sérieusement possible
comme vous l'avez lancé le secret
d'alarme là il y avait donc le
gouvernement était à l'écoute j'imagine
aujourd'hui puisqu'ils étaient
effectivement des représentants du
gouvernement du ministère de
l'Enseignement
alors tous les deux merci d'avoir merci
merci
qu'on comprenne bien les enjeux merci au
plaisir de vous lire normalement merci
beaucoup et bonne chance dans votre
quête de Mauras merci merci pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI